this is chapter 13
on least squares data fitting which is
one of the most important applications
of least squares we'll see
okay so the setup is this um we have a
scalar
y um and we have an n vector
x and we believe that there's some
functional relationship between them
meaning we believe that y is about
approximately equal to f of x
i'll say a little bit more about that
later so here
x is called the independent variable
this is a traditional name for it
and y is called the outcome or the
response
variable now this function f
tells you how x and y are are related
now often x is a feature vector so it's
a vector
whose entries are features associated
with attributes of some item
and then why is something about that
item that we want to predict so that's
that's the most common uh setting here
now we don't know f this function
which gives the quote true unquote
relationship between x and y
and the truth is there usually is no
such f
right that it's simply we have some data
and we simply want to fit a model that
approximately
predicts what y is given x
so um but sometimes there is a there's a
true model or something like that
certainly when we
experiment with methods we will do it
with data that we generate ourselves
and then there's a true model but in
most applications there's no such
thing as f doesn't exist it's a fantasy
now we're going to be building our model
or data fitting
methods based on some data and so
data we're going to have a set of
capital n
data points and they're going to be f x
1 superscript 1 up to x superscript
capital n
uh those and the associated outcomes as
the independent variables
and the associated outcomes are going to
be y 1 up to y
n and we're using superscript here to
index
which of the data examples we have right
so we refer to x superscript i y
superscript i
as the i data pair
and if you want to refer to a component
in x you would have x superscript i sub
j that's the jth component of the ith
data point so this is this is a data set
it's called
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to try to build an approximate
model using this
data set now our model
we're going to denote by f hat and as
i've said before
it is in applied math it is kind of a
convention
that hat means an approximation of
something so the idea here is
f hat is supposed to be an approximation
of f
this uh true uh this true function which
in fact probably doesn't even exist
anyway
but the idea is that this thing is
supposed to guess
or make an approximation of y is given x
okay so uh we'll be focusing
on a very simple set of um
a very simple model form in which
f hat of x is equal to a linear
combination
of f one of x up to f p of x
uh with coefficients theta one through
theta p um now these
these f's these fi f1 f2 f3 those are
those are so-called basis functions and
and we're going to choose them and we'll
say a little bit later about
uh how would you choose them and why
would you choose them one way or another
that kind of thing these are the basis
functions
and then theta i are the model
parameters that we choose
right so uh so the idea is you first you
pick the basis functions
and then you choose the model parameters
right which are just numbers uh they're
theta 1
up to theta p now here the way we
interpret is this
is if i is in general
y hat equals f hat of x
this number y hat is our guess
as to what the the s the y the outcome
or label associated with x would be
um so this is our guess and of course we
can have a drum roll and
and and reveal y and y hat and
just see how close we are okay so
if we look at our known data f hat of x
i is y hat i we're going to call that
that's our prediction of what y
i is now that's one that's in our data
set so the truth is
we know what what we know this that's a
number and we know this number
and and we can uh of course what we'd
like i mean ideally we'd like them to be
well equal
then i'd have a perfect predictor of of
what's happening so but
we're gonna see that's for a number of
reasons uh not a good idea but
nevertheless
um uh so what we're gonna do is uh
we're gonna actually back off and say
that we want
actually what we really like is the
predictions to be close to the true
values
we'll we'll get to what we'd really like
shortly actually in the next section
okay so this brings us to least squares
data bidding
so the prediction error or residual on
the ice data
point is the true value minus the
predicted value
so that's that's it but by the way some
people reverse it the other way around
and so on but
but it's actually not for us it's not
going to matter
so least squares data fitting says this
choose the model parameters theta i to
minimize the rms prediction error
on the data set and that's simply the
sum of the squares
of the residuals uh divided by n
there's capital n of them and then you
take the square root so that's root mean
squared
now that's the that's the that's the rms
error on our prediction set and remember
what each of these is
each of these is the difference between
the true value
and what you predicted right so if this
is small
you would say that your model is pretty
good
if it's large your model is well pretty
poor
now this method of choosing the
parameters theta
this can be reduced to a least squares
problem and therefore we can
easily solve it um even when these are
quite big
so let me explain how that works um so
let's express
our data set um and we're gonna have
several things we're gonna have y i
that's actually the the true observed
uh labels or uh sorry outcomes um
we'll have y hat i that's what our model
is predicting
now y hat i is a function of our thetas
i mean it's also a function of the
choice of f's but we're assuming that
the choice of the basis functions is
fixed right so
so y hat i is our prediction
on the i data sample and then
ri of course is the difference of the
two
is the residual or prediction error lots
of other ways to call it
uh so and these are going to be n
vectors and that means that
uh the jth entry of it is the jth
is is the error and it is the
outcome prediction and residual or error
on the jth
data example okay so these are now
vectors
now if you look at rms our the
superscript d means data
on our data set so the rms value
of rd that's just the rms prediction
error and that's what we want to
minimize we want to choose the theta to
minimize that so
we're going to form an n by p matrix a
and the elements are going to be
a i j equals f j of x i
so it's the j basis function evaluated
at the ith
data point uh data um the the
independent uh in the independent uh
variable value right and so with this
definition
we get a very compact matrix vector
equation
it says our predictions are equal to
this matrix a
multiplied by theta so this this makes
it very clear by the way
how um the predictions depend on theta
and what we see is it's linear uh in
this case now
this is that's why we call it a linear
in the parameters model
because the predictions are linear
functions
of the parameters okay now of course
once we choose the parameters they don't
vary and it's not relevant that your
model is linear in the parameters
anymore but
nevertheless that's it okay so
least squares data fitting says please
minimize the well the rms value that's
the same as minimizing the norm squared
so of our d but that's y d minus y hat d
norm squared and that's equal to this
and we quickly get it we have moved
moved it around and we now have a least
squares problem
so that's it now we know everything
we then know that in fact the optimal
theta
this is assuming that the columns of a
are linearly independent okay assuming
that's the case
then theta hat is a transpose a inverse
a transpose y
that's a formula for it in fact we don't
compute it that way
we would compute it by let's say a qr
factorization as as we saw last time
also i should say in most languages this
would look like
this it would simply say that theta
hat is a
backslash y d now what i do want to
remind you of
is that is not mathematical notation
that is code
uh so if you're among friends or
something like that or people who know
about this
you can write that down but you know
don't write that or mention that
if you have friends who are
mathematicians or something like that so
uh but so that's it so basically this is
this this page can be implemented very
shortly
uh basically it says the first thing you
do is you create the matrix
number one then you do this and then you
get your parameters and now you have
your
prediction model um now if i take a
theta hat minus y squared that is the
the smallest
norm squared value that can take and if
i divide by n that's called the
minimum mean square error fitting
fitting error and i think it's
minimum mean square error mmse so you
will see that
um you'll see that several places right
the idea of mmsc those
everyone will just assume you know that
acronym
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to look
at um some at essentially the
simplest possible uh prediction model or
model
and it's a constant model and that's
obtained it's a that's crazy goes like
this
um my i have one basis function only so
p equals one
and and here's my my first basis
function it's f
one of x is equal to one always period
that's it just one
okay um and so the model is well it's
theta one times
f1 of x but f1 of x is one so it's just
theta one and so
this is a fancy way of saying our model
is just a number
so it's gonna so i will here's our
here's our
prediction model is you would say uh
what do you think the demand for xyz is
going to be tomorrow and you say 13.1
and you go then the next day they come
back and they say what's the demand for
blah blah and you'd say
13.1 and so on so the idea is it's a
it's a pretty simple model
uh it's simply a constant that's it
um okay uh so
let's we can actually just work it out
from the formula
um so here a is simply the ones vector
right it's
p equals one so the width of a is only
one
and in fact what you're supposed to plug
into this matrix a is the value
of that basis function at that data
point but that's always one
so a is simply the vector of ones
well here's the formula it's just theta
transpose theta inverse you know
theta you know one sorry one transpose
one inverse
one transpose y d but one transpose one
is just
n capital n it's the number right
because it's a sum of
n numbers each of which is the product
of one and one otherwise known as n
um so what this is and one transpose
y d is the average that's i'm sorry it's
the sum of y d
so this is the sum divided by n that's
the average
um and that's really cool so it says
and you know it in retrospect it's
extremely intuitive right what it says
is that if you want to use a constant
model
to summarize or predict some data
you should simply look at the mean of
what that data has been
and guess that right so if you want to
if you want to guess
the temperature in palo alto let's say
well based on nothing as a constant you
would simply take the
mean the mean and you'd say that's what
it is okay that's the temperature
okay now interestingly the minimum mean
squared error
is the standard deviation of yd
squared right and so the rms error the
optimal rms error is the standard
deviation
so this is actually a very good
interpretation of what the standard
deviation is so if i tell you
that i have some data y d and i say well
the mean is five
and the standard deviation is 2.
i mean you can understand that by itself
right it means that basically
roughly speaking yd is kind of above
five and below five about equal amounts
that's false but you know just roughly
and it also tells you that it varies
from five
by about plus minus two so we would not
be surprised if we saw a five in that or
a seven
um of course we could have high we can
have a larger number
of d of hard larger deviations from the
mean which is five
but you know um that that's the uh
uh that's the rough idea okay and so
another interpretation of that is simply
to say
that guessing five is the best constant
predictor
for that for that for that variable y
that's one way to say it
and if you do that if you use that
constant model which is the simplest
model you could possibly have
the uh the rms error is the standard
deviation so
i should say that um sophistic you know
sophisticated models which we
are shortly going to be looking at um
all
basically must be judged against this
simplest model
um it doesn't make any sense right if
you someone walks up to you and says oh
i've created this incredible thing i've
been working for days on
you know putting the model together and
blah blah blah and my rms error is like
you know point two and you go cool dude
that's great
um and you go by the way what was the
standard deviation of the data and if
they say 0.22
then then you can say look you did
basically nothing right
uh so because the constant predictor is
not a whole lot worse than your
complicated predictor so
anyway so this is a very important point
it's actually something a lot of people
well unfortunately some people don't do
but this is what puts everything in
context
it's your baseline model always